now jack don't screw it up this time i
know you're right yeah
screwed up why didn't school what you
are a ufo
what he's a ufo yeah and he just jumped
off the roof oh he didn't
no come on kill him back do it
oh my god yeah that was beautiful
i've got a very special set of skills
i make life hell for one of you or um
that's batman
wait
is
what the [ __ ] what what is that what
oh it's the door okay yeah what are you
doing stop freaking out about everything
god the door was oh my god what is that
it's just oh my god
that wasn't very good i wasn't correct
was i home i was wrong
no you weren't correct mark you
i have to say you are so good
yeah where are you bob come find me pop
oh are we playing with minks now
i can't all right
he's living in the sunlight
it's a fun time what a wonderful time
that is
what does that even mean everything is
racist to jake yeah apparently
yeah everything raises to the irelish
irelish
hairless eyelashes oh they're milo
can i or a hint or something he's living
in the sunlight
this sunlight i i i block off roads
the sunlight oh no are you in are you
outside like meyer simpson though yeah
i'm outside
oh now are you the one opening a door no
where bob how do i how do i get outside
without jumping off the roof like an
idiot well don't jump off the roof go
out there from that door yeah there's
ladders no okay yeah good good good good
that's too [ __ ] easy now oh no no no
what what
jack if you just found a freaking move
you would have been fine
oh my block off road why did
well thanks for having all the fun
without me jack hey i just wanted to
be a good team as soon as you were in
order yeah whatever whatever you know
yeah just come back here what are you
doing oh yeah oh yeah you want brandon
bro you wanna fight i fight you no don't
don't you run away from me
i'm gonna be a piece of glass okay can
we like jump break this how do
you do oh mark what's so good what oh
good so
good ah i i see i see what you're
talking about
yeah do you pick up what i'm putting
down yeah i like it right you you go you
go over there okay
huh no other side
balance ouch what are you doing
oh my god he's [ __ ] staying what what
i'm swallowing
uh some lost souls up here okay where is
the rooftop over here by the uh
satellite and the oh man off off the
blue roof over on the white
the white i just wanted to let you know
that this is all your fault it's cool he
has no idea
i uh yeah just go just you know
he has no idea he's totally oblivious oh
is that what
i think i i think these are not how they
normally are oh no
i'm splishing in the pool i got this
jack watch this oh this water
is
yeah you gave us something uh something
value
dude yeah guys here here rap for us here
we go
um my name
is mark and i am a jar [ __ ] oh no no
no no i can't move oh that wasn't yeah
listen mark
all right sorry jack i killed you
accidentally uh and now it's your turn
to rap jack you can do it
okay jack wrap to save my life
my name is jack and i'm here to say i'm
going to [ __ ] you up
in your face wow that was actually
pretty good yeah
uh what are you doing for my cousin
what'd you do to jimmy we have a very
strict policy
and uh you didn't
jack i think they were onto us i just
want to say
100 marks
dude i don't even know anymore i thought
i was onto something and that was
totally wrong
is that a slightly
all right all right so um honest opinion
how does this look
that actually looks really good really
yeah because i can't move so this is how
it looks i figure it looks good though
she's also outside oh yeah i am outside
i could give you that i'm outside all
right we're
on our way how the hell do we get
outside i'm pretty close to like some
grass
and stuff so oh god okay
that's kind of outside jackie oh there
he is
hey jack how's it going welcome welcome
to my gardening area
yeah someone here okay now i just gotta
is this pile of sand yes i'm the whole
pile of sand
oh it's over
i uh uh let's see what other hints well
i i am green
is that a hint um
i've got some green on me yeah are you
kermit the frog
yeah uh it's not easy being green permit
the frog here
yeah i know i did not turn into a cactus
that's
you know that that phrase is actually
pretty meaningful to me it is
not easy being green people would be
more responsible
about it he's a little prickly oh he's
not a cactus
like hiding in uh these
actually i'm actually a computer mouse
inside a cactus that would be the
douchiest thing
you could possibly do don't even joke
about that [ __ ] no i i'm not yeah
are you like one of those little
cactuses hiding in these no no no no no
no
not even a cactus don't even don't even
be fooled by that
wait a minute i'm pretty big wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute
wait a minute jack yes i'm a coming come
over here
something don't seem right here what
something is all
wrong up here is that prickly
well that's one
wow oh okay here we go
oh i don't know what i'm doing well this
isn't good
oh why didn't you know you're gonna be
around this corner what are you doing
we have an issue in the basement is this
how we're going to do it
i'll let you go go find bob together
mark no no no
no you don't know me
where did he go
are you letting mark run away from you
right now oh god
mark did you get away where are you
oh no you lost a giant box
you lost a giant exit not even a little
box
i'm gigantic i won't make that mistake
again
that's not bad that's not that's not a
good thing that we did their
own i'm still worried really he really
got away still the box
yeah jack i did it my god
jack i did it you good job are you still
alive jack
i am yeah with the lab yes
wait what who even came near me i
haven't seen anything
doing home is that not you dude i'm
so far away from you you don't even
understand
what oh yeah i still know
you guys are just looking for mark and
you can't find them and you still forget
that i'm here as well where are you jack
no one oh god there's an elevator
hi somebody passed me not too long ago
was it a box did a box pass you
no i would have recognized that you
would have
ah you'd be surprised apparently nobody
else can find a box
i made a mistake and the comment section
is gonna be
inundated right i know they're never
gonna let let
me forget that ever i'm gonna do like 10
replays of it just
oh mark nope don't you gonna lose me
again
oh my god again this time
this time it's totally going down where
the hell is all this
mark nope this time you're going down
what makes you think that stop running
from your feet
nope where are you going here now
oh my god we were outside oh wow thank
you god
jack you don't even look normal please
don't cut that mark
you're gonna kill me if you do i'm gonna
get like oh
so many so many replays i'm gonna put up
a 10 hour version of you
missing me okay you're in the room with
the skylight i'm on the skylight
let's see okay come on down no no no no
no no no no
the glass killed me oh come on
wait a minute i think i saw something
over there
oh that's right mark something didn't
seem right no no
oh pot huh
there we go all right
it's you and me i am uh i'm making the
bedrock
if you know what i mean
not even
oh my god
now who's getting all the replays
i didn't even do that on purpose to make
you feel better i'm just like
dumb did you did you mean to do that no
yes actually yes i did that was totally
intentional oh
[ __ ] oh my god my face hurts shut up
you just gotta not to be stupid oh well
then maybe you're a barrel huh how about
that
oh oh mark don't
don't be that guy you were that guy i
told you
bob we know where he is jack what are
you gonna do now
i'm gonna be fine what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
oh no jack you got no options
your dunsies your dunzo your dunion
rings
all right i don't know if we know where
he is as much as you think we know where
he is
oh yeah he is barrel because you give me
away
well you you now you
called me dumb so maybe you deserve
to die uh-oh um
a trainer coming the train of death is
on its way
the pain drain is coming the pain drain
have you seen
any moving barrels there oh no uh
jack you should just stay in the trash
where you belong do you see him
because it's yeah like i have a choice
in the trash
yeah you're just the sky may have given
it away too much
jack i'm sorry
yeah if you hadn't said that i don't
know if i would have checked over there
ah
well see now they're stuck in the trash
they can't get out oh just don't come in
this room
and i will be fine i'm gonna come in
that room so hard you don't even know
now don't come in here
you just wait come all over that room
don't don't dude
we're both coming in that room i am
stuck
where are you how did that even happen
where's the tower where it was last time
the trash can
oh okay what's the box power
oh the magic magic tower yeah i know you
have just do
you have your grenades still no no
you just try your try your shotgun just
keep going
here you don't know mark you should go
down wait jack yeah
way down here are you stuck what
happened down to the train come down
where the trains
thank you no mark's gonna get stuck oh
god no no no no no
i shot all three things and they did
nothing they did not
they did nothing we got a minute and 30
to find babe
uh well i will stay exactly where i am
i'm pretty confident
i'm i am uh
uh you might magnificent spot
you might think of batman when you see
me what
okay let me get in my batman mode that's
like the worst clue ever but i can't
move and i'm like the biggest [ __ ]
possible thing i could have become
oh you are i know where you are uh the
couches are pretty big
yeah the batman batman oh
batman batman
yeah jack come to the garage where the
car is wait no no give me there's
nothing
there there's nothing there give me
another prop and uh
uh no i don't think i will jack get here
quickly a few seconds
this way come on you were on the street
it's on the street jack
the garage outside mark just scooched
the props i know i never get there in
time i never get there i'm the opposite
side now
and uh just kill him oh i can't become
oh
what are you to do now bob uh
i wish i had a gun i have a gun out of
me here
whoa what did i do what is that did that
even hurt you
no it's not hurting
i don't have any more ah
uh no i gotta kill
oh and you just missed it jack you just
missed it who was it
yes